[Music]
[Music]
for centuries Koreans have believed in
the municipal properties of a folk
remedy called Dugan or in English bamboo
salt young Chui Gilman whatever mineral
woven bamboo salt is ubiquitous in South
Korea it is made by repeatedly roasting
salt in stocks of bamboo its adherents
claim it combats disease indigestion and
pain but what's certain is it's not easy
to make material given Y Junipero Honda
Integra John Doe LCD food ago has an
American Jaguar - elidio g3p Alan
groaning from code eons ago video
the definitive method was fashioned in
the early 20th century by a famed
medicine man named Kim ilhoon near the
end of Kim Alan's life his son Kim Yoon
se established a bamboo salt company
that preserved and industrialised the
family's salt making method headed on
youngin cancer Amita tomato-y tonometry
anechoic we are open s o sanam o
challenge Apollo tell me de queso de
Namur otra vez una muchacha go so
conclusion on Culp Assad regime are open
tienen una mujer de Gredos o substantive
approach OD hazel Venusian young Haden
go sir sickle jung han gauri pero según
una prisa Henrickson taniyama phenom
what animal characters of androgen Han
gajanan venerable New England for Kim
the three year process is worth every
minute
producing it is a way to honor both this
uniquely Korean remedy and his father's
legacy
[Music]
until sixty years ago all soy sauce was
made like this and it tasted totally
different but there's a small island off
the eastern coast of Japan with the town
center called the country of soy sauce
here despite a government ordinance to
modernize production a small group of
people continued to make it the
traditional way
Yasuo Yamamoto is one of those people
I'm a new Honda bento Tokina keo keo no
I'll show you the new Hornets curry also
no more each parcel or kittymuz
potassium Iowa Yamamoto so des casino
yah yah jacuzzi Onancock so it's
akatsuki las Cuates reward I made a OD
sandeman he owes us an asado para para
nada show is costomer
Yamamoto isn't doing this alone a few of
the people who helped him mr. Sakaguchi
carpenter and craftsman miss takahashi
head assistant miss Taguchi head of
shipping miss Yoshioka in charge of soy
bottle labeling oh and this is our cab
driver he drove us here hey we should
all show you other smith tomatoes acaba
caranesca rhythm all can also touch got
pay Maria caddy
kikuno ROIC or certain animals which
okinawa serotonin as your new dives of
comedy
she'll need a asserts good on the scale
ever more a panda Gina thank you
they were all so much good in a sense
instead of using steel he uses large
bamboo barrels and these he has to make
himself
these barrels are the main
differentiating factor between the soy
sauce you know and his it ultimately
comes down to how the soybeans are
fermenting inside these bamboo barrels
which bestow auto vast a raucous take on
the stable more hallowed Ohio dismiss so
no Tatanka Morano
Oh Tony negara have Olga dough you who
know Konerko Honda's be considered a
form of The Talisman traditional
commercial production of soy sauce takes
only a few months but for Yamamoto it
takes much longer
Videla says all Cortana juicy Carla
yeah panini mechanics Zoe nicole says
all coated ask a little more multi is
almost a Romeo intactness the sepoys she
immediately how to Canada in Quebec a
constant Salado Jukes a stamina or
suppose a foreign language
it seems like a lot of work to go
through first soy sauce but for Yamamoto
this is what soy sauce is supposed to
taste like so it's all worth it all so
let's go to keenness ai ko Serena said
IA and no cost I ran over
oh that's much equal to this Yamamoto
son whose soy sauce is better yours for
the big guys so he'll watch it off hello
everyone and welcome to the sun goal
here in big no utah my name is Missy
Stewart and today we're going to make
our famous tickle my pickle pie is a
dessert it's not the sweetest pie we
have but it is the most original took a
lot of imagination I think to invent a
dessert pie with a pickle in it the
original owner found the recipe in a
magazine she didn't like the recipe at
all so she changed it around and now the
pickle pie is the very best jazz far as
I know we are the only place that makes
the pickle pie
in pickle pie you will find sugar butter
milk eggs lemon extract cornstarch
cinnamon nutmeg and of course the
piglets so we've got this all mixed in
really nice and smooth so now we're
gonna pour it into our unbaked pie shell
to put in the oven scrape the edges so
you get all the flavor and this one
right here is one that we baked this
morning Wow
pickle pie this is delicious a little
tiny bit of cream on it
just gives it that a little bit of sweet
and sour but you need to set off the
taste buds a salty the customers like
the pickle pie but I think the biggest
selling point is curiosity
this look like the d-des this pie tastes
very similar to a pumpkin fire to it
it's not like overpowering here anything
good flavor
wait how sweet it's like super sweet
it's not really sweet I think it's gonna
sell vitriol is a very small little town
we are about three hours from Salt Lake
City then you don't have to live in a
great big city to have good food you
have to have pride and an imagination
it's more than just a pie it's your work
of art it's something that you have done
and it looks pretty and it tastes good
and you can be proud of it
[Music]
burrowed deep in the bedrock of real
monta Sicily is one of the largest salt
mines in Europe and inside that salt
mine is a cathedral
to find this holiest of underground
places you'll have to navigate 62 miles
of spacious pattern tunnels concentric
circles made 5 million years ago from
the evaporation of an ancient ocean
adorn the walls lighter rings indicate a
hot summer darker indicate the cool of
winter and deep into these swirling
pattern caves you'll find a cathedral
carved out of the salt faced by the
mines workers it comes complete with an
altar steps and a crucifix eight hundred
worshipers can fit inside and the space
is consecrated in the name of Saint
Barbara the patron saint of miners the
salt mine itself plays a large role in
the local economy and produces around
500,000 tons of salt each year but its
value to the spirit and the eye is
unmatched located in Romania around 400
feet below the town surface is the
Celina tirta an underground theme park
inside one of the oldest salt mines in
the world
[Music]
Syleena tirta is believed to be nearly
2000 years old during its time as a salt
mine it is estimated that over three
billion tons of salt was excavated from
the walls before mining stopped in 1932
[Music]
this underground hub has had various
uses in the past from a cheese storage
center to a World War two bomb shelter
but its current usage is perhaps its
most unique in the early 1990s
Selena torta was carefully converted
into a subterranean theme park and
museum this active Park includes a 180
seat amphitheater an underground lake
with paddle and row boats
[Music]
mini-golf course ping-pong tables and of
course a ferris wheel over two million
people have visited since its opening
the dizzying effect of the place will
leave you feeling like you've left
reality in this subterranean Wonderland
you